>> LAST YEAR AT THIS TIME WE
RAN BETWEEN 3 MUN TO 400
ILLEGAL ENTRIES.
RIGHT NOW WE’RE AT 3400 IN THE
MONTH OF MARCH ALONE
>> CURRENTLY AVERAGING FIVE
ILLEGALS AN HOUR.
>> THERE IS A RULE OF LAW IN
THIS COUNTRY.
WE’RE A COUNTRY OF IMMIGRANTS.
WE ALL WELCOME IMMIGRANTS AND
BENEFICIARIES OF IMMIGRANTS IN
OUR COMMUNITY BUT LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
>> Harris: SHERIFFS COMING
TOGETHER TO SHARE THEIR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE MIGRANT
SURGE AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER
AND AS OF THIS TUESDAY, TWO
DAYS AGO, MORE THAN 23,000
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS ARE IN
U.S. CUSTODY.
ARIZONA GOVERNOR DOUG DUCEY HAS
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
IN HIS STATE DEPLOYING AN
ADDITIONAL 250 NATIONAL GUARD
TROOPS.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN, WE’RE
GETTING WHIPLASH OUT HERE FROM
ALL THE MIXED SIGNALS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN, IF YOU WANT TO
STOP THE DISASTER THAT’S
UNFOLDING HERE AND WILL ONLY
GET WORSE IN THE COMING MONTHS,
YOU SHOULD DECLARE A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
>> Harris: CHAD WOLF IS A
FORMER ACTING DHS SECRETARY AND
HERITAGE FOUNDATION VISITING
FELLOW.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH ME.
WHEN WE’VE TALKED IN THE PAST
WE TALKED ABOUT THE RAMP UP TO
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE,
CATEGORIZE THIS MOMENT THIS
TIME?
>> WELL AGAIN, WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE AN ONGOING CRISIS THAT IS
NOW BECOMING A NATIONAL TRAGEDY
WHAT’S OCCUR AT THE BORDER.
YOU’VE HAD OVER 170,000 ILLEGAL
APPREHENSIONS IN THE MONTH OF
MARCH ALONE.
THE GOVERNOR NOW THOSE NUMBERS
INCREASE AS WE GET LATER INTO
THE MONTHS OF THE SUMMER.
SO AGAIN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
ADDRESS THE SYMPTOMS OF THIS
PROBLEM AND NOT GOING TOWARDS
THE ROOT CAUSES OF IT.
YOU NEED TO ENFORCE THE LAW AND
YOU NEED TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT
BORDER SECURITY.
YOU CAN CONTINUE TO CARE FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT COME
INTO DHS CUSTODY AS THEY SHOULD
BUT THAT ALONE WILL NOT SOLVE
THE PROBLEM.
SO UNFORTUNATELY WHERE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WON’T STEP
UP YOU HAVE GOVERNORS LIKE
ABBOTT IN TEXAS AND DUESY IN
ARIZONA DEPLOYING NATIONAL
GUARD AND THEIR OWN LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO THE BORDER.
A SAD STATE WHEN GOVERNORS HAVE
TO DO THAT BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CHOOSES NOT TO.
>> Harris: WOW, IF THEY DON’T,
YOU HAVE TO ASK THE QUESTION
WHAT HAPPENS IF THE NUMBERS
CONTINUE TO GO UP?
THEY ARE NOT PLATEAUING AT THIS
POINT.
>> WELL, THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE OF THE
NUMBER OF UNACCOMPANIED ALIEN
CHILDREN, OVER 20,000.
53,000 LAST MONTH OF FAMILY
UNITS.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND THOSE
FAMILIES ARE LARGELY BEING
RELEASED.
A SMALL PERCENTAGE ARE BEING
TURNED AROUND BACK TO MEXICO.
A LOT ARE BEING RELEASED INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
AS THE NUMBERS GROW THE SYSTEM
WILL CONTINUE TO BE BROKEN AND
CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR ADDITIONAL
FACILITIES.
>> Harris: HOW DO WE TAKE CARE
OF THEM ALL AND WHERE ARE THEY
GOING?
>> IT IS NOT GOING TO BE ENOUGH.
>> Harris: SOCIAL SERVICES IN
DIFFERENT STATES HAVE TO BE
SEEING THIS INFLUX, TOO.
THAT’S PART OF THE STORY THAT
MAYBE WE JUMP TO NEXT.
I WANT TO GO HERE.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS FINALLY
CONFIRMED THAT THE VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS WILL
MEET WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
GUATEMALA ON MONDAY.
BUT IT WILL BE VIRTUAL.
SO ONLY ROOM FOR ZOOM.
HOWEVER, THEN WE’RE TOLD THE
VICE PRESIDENT WILL TRAVEL TO
THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE IN JUNE
BUT IT HAS BEEN 29 DAYS SINCE
SHE WAS TAPPED TO LEAD THE
ADMINISTRATION’S RESPONSE TO
THE CRISIS AND STILL NO NEWS
CONFERENCE.
WE CAN’T EVEN ASK HER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS.
>> IT’S REALLY UNBELIEVABLE.
AGAIN EITHER THE PRESIDENT OR
THE VICE PRESIDENT HAS NOT GONE
DOWN TO THE BORDER.
I UNDERSTAND THE PRESIDENT IS
BUSY.
THE VICE PRESIDENT SHOULD BE
DOWN THERE TALKING THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND TALKING TO THE
MEN AND WOMEN AND SHERIFFS AND
RANCHERS AND UNDERSTANDING THE
IMPACT THAT THAT MUCH ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION PER MONTH IS HAVING
ON THOSE COMMUNITIES DOWN THERE.
THEN SHE WILL BE BETTER ARMED
TO TALK WITH THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES, MEXICO AND
OTHERS.
TO GO INTO THOSE DISCUSSIONS
WHETHER ON ZOOM OR IN PERSON
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING, WITHOUT
SEEING AND FEELING IT ON THE
BORDER MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO
SENSE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE MEN AND WOMEN
OF THE BORDER PATROL KNOW THIS.
THEY DON’T SEE HER DOWN THERE.
THEY DON’T SEE LEADERSHIP DOWN
THERE.
IT IS A HUGE PROBLEM AND A LOSS
OF CONFIDENCE IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION AS IT MOVES
FORWARD.
>> Harris: CHAD WOLF FORMER